BORDER.
HI, BILL.
YOU ARE ON, BILL.
>> HEY, GUYS, BREAKING NEWS AS
YOU ARE RIGHT NOW, JUST HEARING
THE FEDERAL JUDGE HAS BLOCKED
THE ADMINISTRATION EFFORT TO
DROP THIS ON MONDAY.
BORDER PATROL AGENTS AND D.P.S.,
IT'S WELL COME NEWS BUT ALL IT'S
GOING TO DO IS KICK THE CAN DOWN
THE ROAD.
TITLE 42 WILL HAVE TO DROP AT
SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE, BUT
NOT ON MONDAY.
WE HAVE SEEN AN EXPLOSION IN
NUMBERS.
WE HAD MORE THAN, YOU KNOW, WELL
OVER 230,000 MIGRANT
APPREHENSIONS, THE HIGHEST IN
HISTORY, AND MORE THAN
1.3 MILLION ILLEGAL CROSSINGS
SINCE THE START OF THE FISCAL
YEAR.
EVEN WITH TITLE 42 IN PLACE,
EXPLOSION OF NUMBERS.
WHAT THIS MEANS NOW, FOR CERTAIN
COUNTRIES, CERTAIN DEMOGRAPHICS,
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT WILL STILL
BE ABLE TO EXPELL THEM BACK TO
MEXICO, MEANING THAT YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE SHOWN THIS VIDEO WHERE
ONCE PEOPLE COME ACROSS AND ARE
DETAINED BY BORDER PATROL,
RATHER THAN TAKE THEM TO THE
PROCESSING CENTER AND PAPERWORK
FOR HOURS, THEY CAN PUT THEM
RIGHT BACK TO A BUS, DROP THEM
OFF AT THE PORT OF ENTRY AND
EXPELL THEM BACK TO MEXICO.
IT CAN TAKE LESS THAN AN HOUR.
THEY HAVE USED IT MORE THAN
1.7 MILLION TIMES SINCE MARCH OF
2020, THAT BEING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
FRONT LINE BORDER AGENTS WILL BE
HAPPY TO HEAR THIS NEWS BECAUSE
I'VE BEEN TEXTING WITH THEM FOR
THE PAST SEVERAL WEEKS, EVER
SINCE NEWS CAME DOWN THEY WERE
PLANNING TO GET RID OF THIS ON
MAY 23 AND THEY WERE BASICALLY
SAYING BUCKLE UP, IT'S GOING TO
BE TOTAL ANARCHY AND CHAOS AT
THE BORDER.
D.H.S. OWN PROJECTIONS WERE
SAYING UPWARDS OF 18,000 ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS A DAY COULD HAVE
HAPPENED IF TITLE 42 WERE TO
DROP.
540,000 CROSSING IN ONE MONTH.
MORE THAN HALF A MILLION.
AND PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE,
MORE THAN DOUBLE WHAT WE JUST
SAW LAST MONTH IN APRIL, WHICH
WAS THE HIGHEST IN U.S. HISTORY.
SO, PROBABLY A LITTLE BIT OF A
SIGH OF RELIEF FOR BORDER AGENTS
AND TEXAS LAW ENFORCEMENT, BUT
NOT TOO MUCH.
THESE NUMBERS HAVE BEEN
EXPLODING EVEN WITH TITLE 42 IN
PLACE.
YOU DON'T HAVE WELL OVER 200,000
APPREHENSIONS AT THE BORDER
MONTH AFTER MONTH WITHOUT THERE
BEING A SERIOUS SURGE AT THE
BORDER AND WE HAVE BEEN SHOWING
THE VIDEO ALL DAY LONG.
WE KEEP GETTING THE MASSIVE
GROUPS OF 150 TO 200 CROSSING
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
SO WHAT DOES THIS MEAN BIG
PICTURE, THE ADMINISTRATION
CANNOT GET RID OF TITLE 42 ON
MONDAY AS PLANNED, THEY HAVE TO
KEEP ENFORCING IT WHILE THE
LITIGATION PLAYS OUT.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Jeanine: BILL, YOU KNOW, WHEN
YOU SAY 1.7 MILLION SINCE 2020
HAVE BEEN SENT BACK BECAUSE OF
TITLE 42, HOW DO THEY MAKE A
DECISION THAT SOMEONE SHOULD BE
SENT BACK BASED ON TITLE 42?
WE WERE NOT EVEN COVID TESTING
THE PEOPLE.
HOW DO THEY MAKE THAT DECISION?
>> REALLY IT DEPENDS WHAT
COUNTRY THEY ARE FROM AND WHAT
THE DEMOGRAPHIC IS.
IT STARTED OFF WITH THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES.
GUATEMALA, HONDURAS, EL
SALVADOR.
WE HAD AGREEMENTS WE WOULD PUT
THEM ON FLIGHTS OR KICK THEM
BACK TO MEXICO.
AND DO THE SAME THING WITH
MEXICANS.
ALONG THE WAY ONCE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CHANGED, DEALS
CHANGED WITH COUNTRIES IN THE
NORTHERN TRIANGLE.
NICARAGUANS, THEY WILL NOT TAKE
THE CITIZENS BACK UNLESS THEY
HAVE A PASSPORT.
CUBAN, WE DON'T HAVE A TITLE 42
WITH THEM, AND VENEZUELA, AND
ONE OF THE CRITICISMS HAS BEEN
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CAN
JUST, YOU KNOW, PUT THEM ON A
BUS AND SEND THEM BACK TO
MEXICO.
FOR SOME DEMOGRAPHICS, THEY
PREFER TO PUT THEM ON AN
AIRPLANE AND SEND THEM BACK, AND
YOU KNOW, YEAH, THE BORDER
PATROL UNION SAYS IF WE REALLY
WANT TO ENFORCE TITLE 42 ACROSS
THE BOARD, KICK EVERYBODY BACK
TO MEXICO.
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT DONE
THAT.
THEY HAVE PREFERRED TO TRY TO
FLY SOME PEOPLE BACK AND WHEN
THE HOST COUNTRIES DON'T
COOPERATE THEY CAN'T DO IT.
>> Jeanine: I UNDERSTAND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, BILL.
THE QUESTION I'M GETTING AT
LAWRENCE IS THE FACT THAT THE
DECISION TO SEND PEOPLE BACK TO
THE ORIGINAL COUNTRY HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH 42.
THEY ARE SAYING 42.
BUT IF NICARAGUA WON'T TAKE THEM
BACK, WHAT DOES IT DO FOR 42 OR
NOT.
SEEMS 42 IS USED IN SOME CASES
BUT NOT OTHERS.
>> BASED ON THE REPORT AND I'VE
DONE IT AT THE BORDER, 42 HAS
BEEN USED AS A BAND AID.
IT'S NOT GOING TO FIX THE MASS
PROBLEM AT THE BORDER.
ON ANOTHER NOTE, DID THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION A FAVOR HERE.
BUT NUMBER TWO, AS A RESULT OF
THE JUDGE MAKING THIS DECISION,
A LOT OF WOMEN AND CHILDREN ARE
GOING TO BE PLACED IN DANGER
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER.
A LOT OF THE FOLKS ASK WHY ARE
THEY BRINGING THE CHILDREN
ACROSS THE BORDER, IT'S A
TICKET.
THEY KNOW THEY CAN GET ACROSS
AND THAT -- THIS IS WHY YOU
DON'T SEE A LOT OF PEOPLE
RUNNING AWAY AT THE BORDER.
MOST OF THE RUNNERS THAT YOU SEE
ARE SINGLE ADULT MALES BECAUSE
THEY REALIZE THEY CAN'T COME
INTO THE COUNTRY UNDER TITLE 42.
SO THIS IS GOING TO PUT OUR
BORDER PATROL AGENTS YET AGAIN
IN A BAD POSITION BUT AGAIN,
IT'S GOING TO PUT THESE KIDS AND
THESE WOMEN IN A BAD POSITION AS
WELL.
JOE BIDEN NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND
THIS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A TERRIBLE
ISSUE FOR THOSE DEMOCRATS ON THE
BORDER AREAS.
THEY ARE DEMOCRATS AT HEART.
WHAT THEY ARE SAYING IF THEY
CANNOT DO THIS, THEY UNDERSTAND
THE VOTERS ARE PUTTING A LOT OF
PRESSURE ON THEM BECAUSE OF THIS
ISSUE, AND I'LL NOTE THIS, I
KNOW JESS IS GOING TO HOP IN ON
THIS.
LATINOS AS WELL, OVER 50% ARE
MINORITY.
THE TEXAS D.P.S. DOING A LOT OF
THE PATROLS, THEY ARE
MINORITIES.
LOOK AT THE DISTRICTS AT THE
BORDER, THEY ARE MINORITIES.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF IF YOU HATE
THE PEOPLE AND WANT A BETTER
LIFE, THIS IS ABOUT LAW AND
ORDER AND THE STRAIN OF
RESOURCES IN THE AREA.
>> Jeanine: THE POINT LAWRENCE
MAKES IS A GOOD ONE, HOW IS IT
GOING TO AFFECT THE DEMOCRATS
ALONG THE BOARD RUNNING FOR
OFFICE?
>> IT GIVES A FEW MORE MONTHS TO
LISTEN TO DEMOCRATS, ONE WILL BE
CHALLENGING SINEMA IN 2024 IN
ARIZONA, AND FEELS LIKE A TIME
TO PUT TOGETHER A COMMISSION, A
REPUBLICAN RETIRED FROM
CONGRESS, AND GET THEM TOGETHER
FOR A BIPARTISAN PLAN.
WE HAVE TITLE 42, IT WAS A BAND
AID AND A THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION ON THE SHOW
YESTERDAY ABOUT THIS ISSUE WHERE
IT WAS ACKNOWLEDGED THIS IS A
HEALTH POLICY.
TITLE 42 CAME INTO BEING BECAUSE
OF COVID.
WE ARE MOVING TOWARDS A WORLD
WHERE HOPEFULLY COVID IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE RUNNING
THE IMMIGRATION POLICY, WHAT IS
THE NEXT STEP.
HOPEFULLY NOW WE HAVE A FEW
MONTHS, THE SUMMER, VERY HIGH
NUMBERS OF CROSSINGS TO DEAL
WITH THAT, AND WE CAN GO INTO
NOVEMBER WITH THE CLEAR PLAN.
>> Jeanine: OK, WRAP IT UP FOR
US.
>> IT IS A TESTAMENT TO HOW
APPEALING OUR SYSTEMIC RACIST
COUNTRY IS THAT MILLIONS OF
NONWHITES WANT TO COME HERE.
AS LONG AS WE CARE ABOUT
IMMIGRATION, IT'S LIKE CRIME AND
INFLATION, THE WHITE HOUSE WON'T
BECAUSE IN THEIR VIEW WE ONLY
VIEW THESE CONCERNS BECAUSE WE
ARE DEPLORABLES EMBRACING
REPLACEMENT THEORY.
WHEN ALL IT IS, WHETHER IT'S
CRIME OR INFLATION OR
IMMIGRATION, IT'S ABOUT PROCESS.
IT'S ABOUT RULES.
IT'S NOT ABOUT PEOPLE.
WE ARE A BIG -- REPUBLICANS AND
CONSERVATIVES AND LIBERTARIANS,
WE ARE ALL ABOUT SYSTEMS.
WE JUST WANT YOU TO BE PART OF
THE SYSTEM AND DO IT THE RIGHT
WAY, AND SO WHAT'S HAPPENING
NOW, YOU SEE A LOT OF PEOPLE
PAINTING A BROAD BRUSH OF THE
RACISM STUFF AND THEIR WAY OF
DOING IT HERE LIKE THEY DID WITH
CRIME ELSEWHERE.
>> Jeanine: GO AHEAD, KATIE.
>> THE BIGGER ISSUE OF THE
SYSTEM, BILL REPORTED THERE WAS
AN AMERICAN CITIZEN ARRESTED IN
TEXAS FOR HELPING TO SMUGGLE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ACROSS THE
BORDER.
BIGGER PICTURE, THE LONGER THIS
LAWLESSNESS GOES ON AND THE
MISSION IS TO PROCESS PEOPLE,
NOT TO ENFORCE THE BORDER AND
PROTECT THE COUNTRY, THAT
CORRUPTION WILL BREED AND IT
WILL GET COMPLETELY OUT OF
CONTROL.
IT WILL REACH PUBLIC OFFICIALS,
LAW ENFORCEMENT, SO THERE IS A
LONGER TERM CONSEQUENCE TO
ALLOWING THIS TYPE OF
LAWLESSNESS TO CONTINUE AND ONCE
IT'S IN THOSE SYSTEMS, WE LOOK
LIKE THE MEXICO CORRUPTION AND
THAT'S A LOT OF REASON WHY IT'S
HAPPENING AS WELL AND ONCE YOU
GET TO THAT POINT, IT'S
DIFFICULT TO GO BACK.
>> Jeanine: THE SAD PART ABOUT
IT IS WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
FLYING PEOPLE I